so a long time ago Donald Trump in a it
wasn't use it wasn't like a bus or
something right and he said that when
you're famous women let you grab him by
that you know talking about mmm-hmm and
this was like a huge deal yeah everybody
was yelling they were like we cannot
have you know the president saying these
things and to this day they still use
that against them in their knocking well
well there's been an accusation against
Joe Biden for a while Joe Biden as many
of you know is probably going to be the
Democratic primary
you know nominee he's gonna win boy I
did not go in the general but apparently
there's a story where a woman named Tara
Reid was working in his office in the
90s Joe Biden actually grabbed her
pushed up against the wall and then
followed through yeah on what Donald
Trump had said and grabbed her got some
more support Lee right what went up in
there it was my father down
so simply grabbing he would try to keep
we try to keep things family-friendly
consider we just talked about YouTube
purging everybody so we know we fight
within the limits we can unfortunately
but Alyssa Milano has just come out in
Joe Biden's defense touting the
importance of due process which is
ridiculous agreed considering she was
dressed up like a Handmaid's Tale woman
for you know for the cabin protesting
the Kavanagh thing saying zero-tolerance
but here's where the story gets crazy
because that's that's kind of big news
she went she didn't an interview I think
was an Andy Cohen and she was like well
here's the thing we must believe women
but men deserve due process and it's
like oh dude oh thanks now they do
thanks now yeah here's what gets crazy
though she Rose McGowan who is
considered like another high-profile
leader of the me to movement okay has
just come out and called her like just
in the past like hour whatever a corrupt
DNC fraud it's it's true it's like Biden
is kind of gross and gropey like yeah
totally it's like you can't even hide it
it's like every time he's in the
presence of a woman he's sniffing her
hair or grabbing her arm or he had to
apologize for it and their face is
always like get away from me the old
creepy guy you know it's like funny that
he what he's so much worse than Trump in
that regard but she's defending him I
don't get but but it gets crazier so we
have this is the big breaking news but
remember Asia Argento or Gento whatever
name was no yeah she's another she was
another like leader Raja Argento she was
another me to movement leader she's got
two cool tats she was accused and she
paid out a settlement to this young dude
that she was abusing when he was
underage so now you have you have like
complete hypocrisy at the highest here
is a me-too leader who abused yep yeah
yep
yeah gross like they're all hypocrites
it's almost like oh look at this look
what Alyssa Milano says she tweeted this
there is something to the idea that
people are going to weaponize me to for
political gain just look at the replies
here and look to see who those accounts
are supporting in the primary there
always needs to be a thorough vetting of
accusations
wow talk about disgusting vile evil
manipulative con artists Wow how else do
you describe that what's the end goal of
being a vile slime bag and I don't I
don't really insult people but I'm going
for the emotional reaction here man oh
and why is Alyssa Milano and you known
for anything anyway she's famous actress
for from what she's well so I don't I
don't think I know I don't think I'm
making a mistake I I'm just I'm just hey
this is John I don't know who she is
I never watched anything with her in it
wasn't she what's charmed I don't know
what that is show yeah I never thought
you know what it is yeah I never watched
it though but III didn't know that she
was one of the was it on it wasn't she
on some show in the 80s when she's a
little kid it's a mistake to say oh I
don't know she is because she's still
working actively in Hollywood I'm just
I'm just making fun he's curious I she's
like why is she's a celebrity and she's
got ten followers
man she's a high-profile activist and
she's a fair-weather activist it's no no
no no that's not fair no fair weather
activists at least get up sometimes for
the cause okay what she's doing is
manipulating people for political
brownie points yeah that's a good point
check this out so Rose McGowan just I
think will just pull up the tweet from
Rose you are a fraud this is about
holding oh wait wait wait what is this
oh yeah yeah Wow amazing so let's just
pull the tweet straight up wait I had
the story but we'll put the tweet I have
I have respect for Rose she says in
response to Alyssa Milano saying I
explained my silence on the allegations
against Joe Biden she goes you are a
fraud this is about holding the media
accountable you go after Trump and
Cavanaugh saying believe victims you are
a lie you have always been a lie the
corrupt DNC is in on a smear job of tar
Reed so are you shame I was just
watching an interview of her from
weather who me two things started and
she was not on good terms felissa then
she literally said you were a lie
Wow what she's called her up before she
has during the Kavanaugh thing she's
like yeah you're getting you're getting
Fame from this and that's all you care
about Wow I'm impressed
I dig it she burned her I appreciate
that let's see if we can nail her people
are responding look at this tweet
someone someone tweeted this adder zero
tolerance if we don't halt
oh no I think this might be a fake tweet
yeah zero well so here's what they're
reporting she tweeted zero tolerance if
we don't hold all accountable for a
horrible behavior nothing changes sorry
Al Franken you should not be in a
position to represent the female
constituents in your state that might be
real if I can check I can look yeah
because because someone said I fixed it
me too I don't know if this is different
or whatever what a bunch of people have
been highlighting past tweets she made
she's saying it's a smear oh it's a
conspiracy of course it is Alyssa Milano
believes the conspiracy to smear the
campaign probably is that what it is is
that yes four and Wu and Warren not
endorsing Bernie when their policies
line up to me means she was telling the
truth about what he said us you know
what man she said I believe women it is
my opinion that you can't conflate the
violent criminal assault described about
dr. Ford and an uncomfortable invasion
of personal space and boundaries
described by Flores these two things
aren't the same no matter how hard your
network tries to spin it you know the
allegations against Brett Kavanaugh were
what that when he was a teenager at a
party he threw a young woman on the bed
and him and his buddy jumped on top of
her and then she ran away
oh he like she said like he held her
down I don't know and then his buddy
jumped on him they rolled over and she
got up and ran off no witness
corroborated it okay
her friend said I don't remember what
you're talking about she couldn't she
didn't know where it happened it was 36
years ago or so
thing okay she didn't know how she got
there she didn't know where it was
she didn't how she got home and no one
crumbled anything and not only that but
Christine Bosley Ford I'm gonna say it
she lied she said that and already I
know that there's much people who you
don't know left are triggered listening
to this yeah well she said she was
afraid to fly
following this stuff okay and then
someone asked her like don't you fly all
the time for work and she goes yes it's
like wait what she claimed that she got
like a second door in southern her house
because she's terrified now she was
traumatized it's like dude you're like
yeah she's 36 years later she she's now
traumatized or she's yeah always always
been I guess and then someone else came
out and said that the reason she got the
door in southern her house was because
she was air being being it
she was running your business right the
other said her house yeah like the whole
thing was just fronting and guess what
you end up with this this you know woman
share these photos this from Robbie
Starbuck he tweeted this is the same
Alyssa Milano who told you to believe
women she uses all allegations as a
weapon against political opponents with
zero evidence now she won't drop her
endorsement of Joe Biden after he was
credibly accused I love that by his
former staff of assault look at this she
dresses like you know The Handmaid's
Tale it's oh so stupid emails now the
reason I brought up who is this person
it's it's not because of like is she
someone of someone that we can listen to
it's like anyone can be if they have the
right opinion but I see her doing this
kind of stuff and it's a publicity stunt
totally that's what I'm aiming at you
know like so that's what it is it's like
she had her chance to get in the light
and she everyone was was making memes of
her sitting behind like in the courtroom
yep you know and I don't remember she
had like a paper holding up they put
different things on the paper or
whatever it's like people were talking
about her three points there you go
million followers right that's what it's
all about
yes I think raising her profile yep so
she can get access now she's not gonna
be an a-lister you know because this is
poison yeah move it movies look at that
I mean they've danced around it they've
tried doing some of the stuff yes she if
she wanted to backed she could probably
get a job in like a she is acting a
c-list horror film no she's doing like
Netflix and haven't like house on the
Haunted Hill 8 no no no no she's doing
like good stuff
sure she's doing legit stuff well
last movie she was in white want to pull
up Ryan DB I was do it it's it's it's a
mistake to go down this route to try and
argue that like she's a d-list or
something no no all I was saying is that
this seems like everything that is that
I see about her is a publicity stunt
I just want more attention you know why
why would she go for Biden right now
makes absolutely no sense other than
look how many people are talking about
her again she's on she's on a TV series
from 2018-2019 called insatiable
imaginary lines 2020 she's in
post-production on two projects she's in
a miniseries so but it's not even an
argument it's not an argument to be
alike you're a washed-up actress I don't
like that argument matter I'm not even
saying that whether she's washed up or
not I mean I just I can honestly say
I've never watched any of these things
that she's been in but still she has all
this influence she's been I guess so
hold on not you're wrong you won't ever
seen what Everly Hills Chihuahua to she
was she was the voice of Bimini in
Beverly Hills Chihuahua that's where I
know all right
she was what it was she was in
ghostbusters the video game you're right
she was a match she was a my name is
Earl I take nothing yeah my name is Earl
actually I think charmed was like the
biggest thing she did in recent history
but she was on Spin City she was in
Melrose Place briefly she did a bunch of
Melrose Place didn't she do like a big
show there we go yeah who's the boss
there it is okay yeah she was
Shmuel antha I'm Atlanta
yes Mille antha is that how they
pronounced it no that's how Rick and
Morty pronounced it Oh Shmuel Angela so
yeah yeah a lot of people have they
tried to do like an emotional attack
against her yeah
and it actually empowers her side
because when you attack someone based on
something that's completely nothing to
do with anything it's like you're
proving my point
no no it's just the people aren't the
people like any any right look the
tribalists are never gonna give up their
position no matter what yeah but if
there's a regular person doesn't know
and they see her saying something like
this man was accused and then you go
used a washed-up actress then
immediately you've lost you've you've
left the argument you're not talking
about
she's doing you're just trying to call
her a stupid dumb dumb you might as well
call her a poopoo face yeah let's talk
about what she really is that's funny
now in the context of her trying to
raise her profile I think it's fair to
bring up that the project she's done are
not a list okay you know the stuff she's
been doing as of lights like and it's
like Netflix and Amazon stuff so it's
not like yeah I mean hey man I'd love to
be underfoot surround the network well
no I mean getting on getting a like a
Netflix show right lot of people intent
next no but it's it's clear that she's
going for some kind of publicity look at
her look at her look at her Twitter
picture it's it's it's it's her doing
activism never Kavanagh resist but she
is this this to me should be proof to
anyone her mission has nothing to do
with helping women helping people
fighting for a cause it's not even about
fighting for the dnc it's about just
shilling for the biggest opportunity so
she wants to pony up to the wealthy
elites the corporatists the
establishment anybody who thinks Joe
Biden is a viable candidate is lying yep
period I can agree with that yeah and
this is why you know we can actually use
it a segue into how they're there
they're starting to purge other YouTube
channels is why they don't like it
because the establishment the big
businesses that love propping up people
like you know Joe Biden that's their
that that's that's what they're for all
right that's what they want
youtubers podcasters you'll notice have
no problem saying Joe Biden that's
insane yeah like look at Joe Rogan the
other day yeah you saw what he said yeah
and now there's articles coming out Joe
Rogan's the canary in the coalmine he
embodies Bernie or bust
he says you know a couple months ago I
probably bought for Bernie now today's I
mean I'd rather vote for Trump because
bernie is out right what's happening
with people is bernie officially out no
but he will yeah I didn't think the
establishments not gonna let Bernie
how's he gonna do know I mean look man I
got I got my issues with Bernie's
policies we can have it we can have a
debate over his policies and I think
he's flip-flopped on certain things but
the dude can speak English
true that's all in that I mean clear
yeah yeah they understand you see you
you saw what Trump said about Biden you
know the other honey so for those who
don't know
at the press briefing he was asked you
know Joe Biden tweeted this about you
when he goes Joe Biden in tweet anything
about me didn't write that a democratic
operative wrote that he's not even
watching this right now and even if he
was he wouldn't understand it supposedly
they had a long talk today they did
about Biden giving his expertly vice
president advice to Trump which is an
interesting you know that they're
spinning it you know I imagine happening
I imagine like the phone rings and Trump
answers and Joe's like oh and Trump's
like how's it going and then Joe starts
muttering is like you know Donald the
thing with you know we have the the case
and and and and dependency with the
shortages and Trump just puts the phone
down and it's like yeah and then Joe's
just saying like see Joe's saying words
right that don't mean anything when you
combine them right so it's like that's
called word no no no actually no
actually he said he's had sakes sakes
sakes what does that mean for Pete's
sakes no no he said we will never let
America sakes second fiddle he mixed two
words second takes nobody said second I
don't know was it was it if he was gonna
say take why is there an S the end of it
anyway back back to the main point then
we can move on to like the YouTube stuff
think about how insane that that all
sounds any honest person will tell you
like even even somebody who doesn't like
Trump like you look at these progressive
personalities people like you know jimmy
dore kyle kolinsky they do not like
Trump and that there's a reason why
they're for Bernie they're like any
honest person as we look at Biden be
like you want him to lead us you want to
put him next to one on a stage making a
sideshow that I honestly Bobby bucks
would it be entertaining to watch that
no in other abuse yeah that's exactly
I'm not the one saying Biden you should
run for president I don't know who is
telling him but Trump versus by then
would be Alyssa Milano endorsing him
even after he was accused look we can we
can feel bad for him as a doting old you
know I'm not I don't watch some attic
room he's
he's running himself he still has the
choice to run or not he's still human
that's alive I think look man the guy
can't speak I can I can barely tell that
he is alive still I don't think he's
talking to get at Bernie's but right
given Biden's he's being propped up by
the establishment if he if the next time
we see him he has dark shades on yo dude
part of me thinks that like every time
he goes in the air there's like some
young DNC people like laughing like just
say this and Joe just like Robert
remember there's Mar over and they're
like laughing like it's a joke
like this there can't be any look he's
got people working for him right yeah
they have to know his mind is jello
mm-hmm right they have to what does she
think like oh he's you know he's an old
guy you know like we got to give him a
new process do you think they paid her
off like oh you know what we can go to
her and have her like back him up so
that she'll bring the whole me to
movement to like not you know bring this
whole thing to like a big thing that
Bruins Biden's chances you know I'd like
to huh you know I'd like to cure I guess
but I have no proof so without evidence
I will not I'll just say that there's I
don't think there's any sane person on
the planet who thinks she's being honest
and this is what this this this is why
Trump Trump's approval rating goes up
because you see people like her and
you're like dude you can't you you like
come on man if you want to lie come up
with a better lie than that yeah yeah
seriously she's like she's like the sky
is green and you're like it's a it's not
it is yeah it's it's not green I know I
can see it like just seven months ago
you were telling me it was blue and it's
still blue it's it's this is what the
craziest thing is to me there have been
several instances where the media has
done things like this mm-hmm
they repeatedly come out and say you
know Trump's response to the you know
the kovat outbreak is terrible and he's
been doing really bad and I'm like the
polls show that most Americans like this
right you coming out and telling them to
their face that no it's actually really
bad is not going to change their minds
it's
make them not trust you because they've
already made up their minds they were
asked about it and they said they'd like
this yeah like the way described it
before is like imagine you have this
really delicious slice of pizza the
pizza and you're like mmm this is so
delicious and also mono goes it's
actually not delicious oh here here I'll
be the news I'll be the news you be you
eating pizza I am I mean hello hello Tim
do you like your pizza I absolutely love
it this just in Tim does not like his
pizza at all exactly bad for you you got
you got a falsely frame it you've got to
be like just right effect check did Tim
actually say he liked his pizza cold no
and then you do this really long-winded
speech about that's the pasta notes
right yeah I was going for the whole
media where they just like I'm just
gonna give him what we want them to give
he hates pizza opinion well well he does
like pizza
yeah there's no evidence to suggest he
likes all pizza all the time everywhere
therefore it's improper to say he likes
you know man for those wondering he
actually really likes pizza he's gonna
like that you know it's just pizzas
really yummy everybody likes me
everybody like you could take bread and
put sauce put anything on it's pretty
good yeah I think take two of them you
put it together you have a sandwich but
who do you think Alyssa Milano was
trying to is like do you think there are
people in this country that are sitting
there and she comes out and says Joe
Biden's gonna be a great president and
they're like wow that's a good point
no no right why should I hear what you
have to say about this cuz you know the
whole thing is that she's she was in
such a prominent place for the me tube
movement and now it's almost like she's
throwing that all out of the window just
to endorse Biden I don't think she is I
think there's a really clever publicity
stunt yeah for example right now we are
talking about her that's what I was
saying yeah that's the first thing I
said it's like nail miss publicity it's
like and who's talking about her
everybody when I when I when I think of
her I don't think of like some like
angelic visit coming down from the
heavens with a beacon of light I see
that old lady from Princess Bride buying
back
Joe Biden president enum like I'm pretty
cringy yeah but this brings me to the
next point we'll get the super chats but
the next the next thing we're talking
about is you'll you'll find why when Joe
Biden comes out in the media and he goes
that the thing about the president and
and and you know with kovat we gotta get
the cars because the shortage when he
when he when he says stuff like that and
you're like what the media corrects him
like without correct what they'll do is
he'll mutter and mumble and then the
headline will say Joe Biden calls for
swift action on coronavirus you're like
no no he didn't he said something about
driving cars during the crisis like what
but driving a car is about moving
quickly so but look at the headlines
when they write about Biden he'll go on
MSNBC or the view or something
he'll just incoherently mumble and then
they'll write this puff piece explaining
what they think he was actually saying
that's a good point cuz I'll read the
headline and I'm like I don't remember
Joe saying that am I getting dementia
what's going yeah but think about I
dimin think about this if they start
getting rid of channels like this one
getting we're getting rid of people like
Luke and many other people they've
gotten rid of yeah how long until they
control the narrative again like the old
days yeah yeah when everyone just
watched the three different news
channels yeah and all someone had to do
is call all three channels and be like
this is what you're reporting now yep
and then they're like hey American
public we're trustworthy this is what's
happening thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you